مجرد بطء ام اكثر لا تكافئ انجازات الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد حتى الان صخب الدعايه
التي
سبقته والى يونيو الماضي بدات اوكرانيا
هجومها المضاد بهدف استعاده الاراضي التي
احتلتها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب وذلك عبر خط
مواجهه يمتد نحو 1000 كيل متر بعد اربعه
اشهر من بدء الهجوم المضاد يقول الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي ان ذلك
الهجوم يتقدم ولو ببطء هو يبعث بهذا جاهدا
رسائل طمانه لداعميه الغربيين وعلى راسهم
واشنطن كي لا يتراجع الدعم وتحديدا
العسكري بعد شهرين من بدئه قالت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
قد تجمد وفي الشهر التالي قال رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه السابق الجنرال مارك
ميلي ان القوات الاوكرانيه كانت حتى خلال
الصيف ابطا مما توقعت الولايات المتحده
متوقعا ان ينتهي الهجوم في غضون 30 الى 45
يوما اي عند اواخر اكتوبر الجاري بحد اقصى
بسبب التغيرات الجويه المتوقعه ما الذي
خيب امال الاوكرانيين في الهجوم المضاد
قبل انطلاقه تحسب الروس ودشنوا على مدار
اشهر خنادق ومخابئ ومصائد دبابات وزرعوا
الاف الالغام في طريق الهجوم الاوكراني
قبل وقوعه كما يشكو الاوكرانيين من رجحان
الكفه الجويه في غير صالحهم خاصه مع تاخر
امدادات مقاتلات اف 16 لعلها تستعيض عن
ذلك التراجع بهجمات الطائرات المسيره
بالمقابل لعبت الدبابات الغربيه التي زودت
بها اوكرانيا دورا مهما في شن ضربات بعيده
المدى ضد خطوط الامداد الروسيه لكن حتى
هذه الدبابات ستعاقب اوحال الامطار
المرتقبه خلال اسابيع يبدو الدعم الغربي
وتحديدا الامريكي لاوكرانيا محفوفا
بالغموض ربما من اجل ذلك اجرى الرئيس
الامريكي يوم الثلاثاء الثالث من اكتوبر
اتصالا هاتفيا جماعيا بحلفائه في كل من
كندا والاتحاد الاوروبي لبحث ما وصفه
البيت الابيض بتنسيق الدعم المستمر
لاوكرانيا وذلك قبل ساعات فقط من حديث
زيلينسكي عن التقدم البطيء للهجوم
المضاد